all for one the criminal mastermind who
was Prime all might's greatest rival and
who kept an iron grip on Japan's
criminal Underworld for hundreds of
years is finally dead he rewound himself
out of existence after he used Aries
Quirk to rewind himself back to his
prime his plan was to go back to his
prime strength crush the heroes and then
forc shigaraki to become his new vessel
but the joint effort by many Heroes and
even his own former servant giganto
Makia ultimately led to his defeat after
even all might himself returned to fight
all for one with a superpowered Iron Man
suit the villain finally met his end at
the hands of none other than katsky
bakugo this is definitely the biggest
death in mha so far but what's next for
the story in recent chapters shigaraki
has become an even bigger danger to
Japan than all for one had ever been
things have gotten crazier than ever and
if you want to stay up to date on all
the latest twists in mha subscribe to
anime opar right now